Voiceover: Few people realize,
that before I made even the
first video for Khan Academy,
the whole point of Khan Academy
was to be a exercise, practice,
feedback, reporting engine for
students, for parents and for teachers.
The first videos were really
just a way to compliment that.
Even if we go back as far back as 2005,
we had a lot of exercises on Khan Academy,
and we got our first real funding in 2010.
That's where we invested most heavily.
Now that the Common Core has come out,
and not only has it come out, not only
have the standards been published,
but now that there's a
sense of the adoptions,
there's a sense of how it
is going to be assessed.
We've decided to do a serious
push to intentionally make sure,
that our exercises match the Common Core.
Now, I want to be very clear here.
Our intention isn't to just
map to the Common Core,
because a lot of states
have happened to adopt it.
Our intention is not to map to just
superficially take some content,
and do a superficial
mapping to the Common Core.
The whole purpose of why we're doing
this is, when we looked at the standards,
when we looked at the items coming
out of the Assessment Consortia,
from Smarter Balanced from park,
we realized that this is a
very, very, very good standard.
It's a rigorous standard.
It's going to measure real
deep student understanding.
And there's going to be a huge
need for students and teachers,
and parents to have resources
where they can get practice,
get feedback, get explanations
around Common Core subjects.
What you see right over here is
a screen of our Common Core site.
This is a place, this
is really a dashboard,
where teachers or parents or even students
can look at Common Core standards,
and then think about which Khan
Academy content maps to that standard.
It's available at
kahnacademy.org/commoncore.
You could go by different grade levels.
Grade 7, grade 8, and you could see
the different Khan Academy exercises,
that cover that standard.
We're actually in process
on doing this right now.
We have a team of teachers, of
professors, of graduate students,
who are working closely with us.
Working very closely with many of the
authors of the Common Core itself,
to make sure that we
intentionally create content,
that really hits at the conceptual
spirit of the Common Core.
Just as a sense of the type
of team we're looking at,
of the type of folks who
are working on this with us,
let me show you our team page.
If you go to the bottom
of any Khan Academy page,
and you go to our content specialists
you'll go to this page right over here.
This is a sample of the folks
who are working with us.
Many of them are experts in developmental
mathematics, in early learning.
Some of them are graduate students,
some of them are professors,
of mathematics at the University level.
It's a really high quality team
of folks who have been helping us,
make sure that we have really deep
and really peer vetted content,
intentionally created for the Common Core.
Once again it's not just because 40
something states have adopted it.
We like the Common Core because we think,
when properly implemented, and
that's a very important thing to say.
When properly implemented, it
is really trying to measure,
deep conceptual understanding.
I encourage you to look at the
bios of all of these folks here,
and we're constantly adding
more and more people,
to collaborate on this effort.
To see the type of content
that they're creating,
it's anything from fairly
simple exercises like this:
"Rewrite the expression 75
plus 20 in the following form."
The whole point of this
is to measure or to test,
does someone really understand
the distributive property.
We've built tools and widgets so that we
can do free expression entry around it.
For example, 75 plus 20 we would
want to factor out, let's see.
We could factor out a 5.
That's 5 times 5 times.
We could write that as 15 plus 4.
I should write this down as a
multiplication symbol just like this.
There you have it.
We've written this in the
form that they wanted,
and we can check our answer.
This is just a very simple
widget to understand,
does someone understand factoring and
undoing the distributive property.
Then there's more complicated problems.
This is really the spirit
of the Common Core.
A lot of people, a lot of
times in an algebra class,
you'll have people talking about
functions, evaluating functions,
but the spirit of the Common
Core's to really understand,
what a function is saying and
really constructing functions.
This is an example of a word
problem, an application problem,
where the student really has
to interpret the function,
to make some fairly nuance conclusions
about what's going to happen,
given the data that's going on.
We also have things like
this, that are widgets,
that actually kind of are, for lack of
a better word, virtual manipulatives,
to help build these content items.
For example here, "Move each
expression to the right category,
"to indicate if each one is less
than, equal to, or greater than 6/7."
A student will say, "Okay, let's see."
5/7 plus 4/7, that's 9/7.
That's greater than 6/7.
Let's see 2 plus ...
Let's see, this is going to be 5/7.
That's less than.
This right over here is
going to be, let's see,
this is going to be exactly equal
to 6/7 and you get the general idea.
Over here.
Then we have things like this,
and these are all written
by experts in their field.
These are written by people who are
looking very closely at the standards.
They're working with specialists,
they're working with some of the folks
who've even written the standards,
and being trained by the folks who
have been written the standards,
to come up with these questions.
To once again, really go at
the conceptual understanding,
that the standard is trying to call out.
Over here, "In the number 47,339
how many times less is the value,
"of the second 3 than the
value of the first 3?"
So the second 3 represents 30.
It's in the tens place, it's 3 tens.
This 3 is in the hundreds place,
it represents 3 hundreds.
30 is 10 times less than 300.
You would type in 10.
This is just an example.
Just coming this fall we have
on the order of 100 exercises,
that have been intentionally
created for the Common Core.
It's not just the exercises.
On top of that we have a
whole series of videos,
that have been intentionally
created for the Common Core as well.
For example this one.
This interpreting features of functions.
We have a whole series of videos
that explain the underlying idea,
behind what's going on.
As we go over the next few months
and definitely over the next year,
especially because Fall of 2014 is when
you're going to have major adoption,
of the Common Core in most of the country,
the goal is to have all of
the major standards covered,
from K through high school
and then even beyond.
For us to really be a super
set of the Common Core.
That's the goal by next Fall.
Even this Fall we want to cover
most of the major standards,
starting this Fall going
through middle school.
We're going to be aggressively
adding content above and beyond that.
For regions, whether
it's states or countries,
that are not using the Common Core,
I want to emphasize that we're
not doing this just to cater,
to the Common Core states.
We want to do this because we want
to have rigorous math content,
and exercises on the site that
would hopefully allow students,
to succeed in any
environment that they're in.
We're really intending to be a super set.
Not a exact covering of the Common Core.